700 m de dénivelé en voie d'être étendu
à ce niveau la louge n'est plus un jeu
d'enfant c'est très difficile pour à
manoeuvrer
ça oui prix sinon c'est génial
c'est pas toi un peu trop vite par la
tombe et alors là on est rempli inspiré
des voisins suisses et autrichiens ou la
luge est une tradition séculaire la
piste a été spécialement aménagé pour
satisfaire les plus expérimentés comme
les débutants alors au niveau sécurité
on a à la fois des virages surélevés
pour permettre lugeur de garder une
meilleure synergie rage être observé une
vitesse relativement importante
belle démonstration est à la fois ci on
est d'une droite plus des banques est de
55 cm de haut pour éviter que les gens
ne me parlent dans la pente et pour
certains effectivement cette pétition
ouverte à d'autres je suis sorti de la
piste
il va tomber dans le trou la petite
frayeur mais malgré les 250 descendeur
quotidien des bocaux sont rares en
vitesse de pointe les engins pour taper
avec rafales à l'erreur mais elle n'est
pas le ski pca3 un superbe adaptation
chirac perd c'est plein d'émotions il
faut pas trop se servir des freins vous
pensent pour avoir plein de sensations
avec 100 l'écran lorsqu'on y ajouter la
neige sous cet angle ne laisse pas de
glace